it's e3 2019 welcome back to the show
floor stage here at games four times
more joined by Michael and we're also
joined by Barbara and magic we're gonna
be talking about the unexpected
announcement one of the big surprises
from e3 2019 a Blair Witch game that
came out of nowhere
I mean I was I was certainly surprised I
I really enjoyed the movie back in the
day one of those cultural phenomenons
and now it's kind of making a comeback
with a video game so I guess guys tell
us how did this thing even happen where
did a Blair Witch game idea come from
and who pitched who and what was the
kind of pitch on that yeah so marriages
sort of like this game that we've been
developing for two years now so we are
really happy that we kept it secret we
can finally tell everybody about it
so after finishing observer we were
looking for another project and it was
also the time when Lionsgate was looking
for a per game company to portray one of
the to portray the The Blair Witch
somatic universe in the game and as we
knew each other just came up naturally
right so that's why we we do a Blair
Witch game it's gonna be it's gonna
follow the similar formula as we
established in our previous titles
layers of fear and observer so it will
be and SPP storage even psychological
horror it will happen in the Blair Witch
cinematic universe and you will play as
Alice who is a former policeman your
main objective main objective at the
beginning of the game will be to find a
missing boy but as soon as you reach
Black Forest everything will turn south
and you'll have much more problems to
take care of right I mean it's almost
kind of a match made in heaven
for you guys right Blair Witch it is
because it makes perfect sense so kind
of how do you how do you approach making
that game and also providing something
fresh and new that isn't too familiar to
what fans of your games may have played
well first of all this is our own take
on what can happen in a Black Hills
forest it's not the recreation of the
movies just our own story set in this
well-known you
and it's really exciting to work with
such a big IP it's an amazing chance for
us yeah Lance great was really
supportive from the start because they
gave us this you know whole freedom on
how we wouldn't want to approach the
topic because from the beginning they
knew that we are more psychological than
survival-horror right but I think what
we have in common is that Claridge and
we as bloggers team we love to you know
ship the environment around the players
to you know
confuse them totally so they have no
idea what's behind them or in front of
them so that's why we even we were even
more excited about this chance and
what's more this year is 2040 bursaries
of diverge franchise so that was even
better for us
they're a unique type of treasure when
handling an IP like do you ever feel
like I need to be more true to the
source material like how do you balance
that the source material material and
your creative vision well we are likely
that this is our own story so we can
take all this background and just put it
there it's in the story it's black hills
forest it's Blair Witch but in the same
time it's a different character it's a
different story
it's a different problem he'll need to
face so we can both take what's the most
iconic about the IP and do something new
with it yeah and what else gates
Studios told us at the start was that
whatever we create in English game will
also become canon for the for the
universe
so it will be referenced in the future
products games movies or that must be a
lot of pressure I mean like Blair Witch
is a it's not like it doesn't have the
kind of cachet that in terms of writing
the fan base is out there constantly
talking about Blair Witch but it has a
very passionate fan base have you been
hearing from them since the announcement
and what other what has the response
been from people who know that universe
and love the movies and now now like oh
there's a video game now it's been
amazing like people on the streets are
coming to us I think sometimes they
didn't even hear about the game it's
like oh you have Blair Witch t-shirt
that's so cool I remember the
and yeah the reaction for the for the
trailer was also amazing like people
were guessing Oh what what is it and
then they saw the logo and it's oh it's
Blair Witch yes finally that's the main
so you mentioned briefly about the kind
of the boy that you're trying to find
can you give us the kind of overview of
the story and how much did you look at
what the story of the original was
compared to what you're doing now
because you know the original movie was
quite mysterious it was not clear what
was going on a lot of times in the very
the the lore of it was what kind of
unravel over time so how have you
approached telling a story within a game
but also keeping the mystique of Blair
of Blair Witch alive well if you played
layers of your observing mystique is our
yeah yeah so it wasn't easy we need to
but as a writer I need to know the whole
story and what is happening and every
moment but player it just needs some of
the parts of the story he needs that he
needs to know what the character is
currently thinking but he doesn't need
to know what is happening around him
that's the part of the mystery like is
it a witch are you just crazy what's
happening right yeah so I guess like the
atmosphere stuff one of the important
things is one of the things that I'm
constantly looking at is this dog I want
to know more about this dog because oh
can you pet the dog confirmed blow which
you can pet the dog breaking breaking it
out now for like one of the things the
reason I'm thinking about is like
isolation is really important these
types of games right and for people to
be scared the idea of people who are
attempting being scared getting scared
the idea of having another presence
around here is somewhat comforting so
can you talk a bit about the
introduction of having the dog and why
you thought it was good to have dog and
how much that dog plays into the actual
game yeah so that's actually pretty
interesting because from the start from
the in the design process we knew that
we don't want to create like a whole
party of characters we wanted
focus on Ellie's especially on his
backstory and his mental state and so on
but the same time we wanted to you know
give this anchor that we can hold on to
if the things are really really going
bad but at least for me personally you
know it's good to have someone in the
forest but it also creates this you know
fear for this person right or an animal
so it's not it's not like the you know
the best-case scenario I'll start one
with you so you're saying you're being
emotionally manipulative using a dog in
Blair the dog is very important to this
story and to the character and we hope
that player will really have this
connection with him that yes I take care
of you and you take care of me because
he's really important both story wise
and mechanical wise so you need to
cooperate with him to really play the
game it's not like you can just I will
go then dog will go there now you need
to have this cooperation you need to
communicate with each other what you
want from him and what he wants from you
are there are other aspects of the
gameplay that you are evolving because I
know that you know you have the
background with layers fear and server
but you also mention that this is still
true to the your past games but how do
you push it forward with Blair or how
are you pushing it forward with Blair
yeah okay so for the starters we have
bullet which is like which was a huge
challenge for us at the start because we
never did an AI before the other team
and we did it from the scratch so it was
like a really really big challenge for
us
what's more if you played layers of fear
observer you know that we never really
did combat in our games there are some
chase sequences or stealth sequences but
you never actually get to fight your
enemies and this time you will be able
to do it it won't be a conventional way
of fighting B because we didn't really
see it fitting for the for the Blair
Witch cinematic universe because you
know you need to be kind of vulnerable
during the game you can't you can have a
chainsaw with you or shotgun but it's
not really how it works so we gave the
player a flashlight which
work kind of similar to how Alice waits
flashlight work you'll be able to fend
off the creatures with it and also I
think what I think we did really which
was really cool was a video camera
mechanic yeah because this is you know
this iconic item from the from the
franchise and you wanted to you know
like make it a really important item in
the game so that's why we we will be
able to solve different puzzles with it
passes that will be directly tied to the
narrative to the story and find out more
about your surroundings and the story of
the game this way so one of the things
I'm really interested in about is like
you guys obviously you delve into the
psychology of a player to figure out how
they you know how to scare them when to
scare them how does that work with the
work that you do Barbara as a writer
like obviously from a gameplay
perspective you wanna you know that all
this is in terms of pacing we need
something to kind of rat you out the
tension and you might be in a different
place with the story at that moment how
do you come together to kind of figure
out the best way to both scare the
player and then present it in a right
narrative framework well with Black
Hills forest where the game takes place
it's hard to control the player like you
can go basically in a totally different
direction than the designers want you to
so you have a lot of freedom but there
are also some parts that you'll be led
by bullets too so you'll basically be
he'll help you to reach the point when
the story but there is something
significant to the story so you can both
wander and you can just follow the
storyline but getting lost in a Black
Hills forest is really easy that's the
point right so yeah it was a challenge
from writer perspective because you
don't know which things the player will
see and you need to have all those
different options all right he saw this
then let's play this dialogue and if he
didn't but he did something else that
led
so there's a lot of dialogues in this
game although if you play just once you
probably won't sell them all right yeah
but that's that's also the replay value
we really put forth into that that you
want to play this game more than once
right so how does that replay value
factored into the way that the story is
told obviously if you have a quite a
defined story where something happens it
kind of takes away from the replay value
right where maybe you experienced things
that are slightly different but does it
always feed back into the same ending or
can it be ending in different different
ways we don't reveal that now okay but
well it's also that once you know this
story you will perceive this story
differently when you play the second
time you understand more you will notice
more things than when you were playing
it for the first time and you really
didn't know what to expect right that's
interesting I guess my other question is
how how far do you want to go with given
that now you know that anything you
create goes into the Blair Witch
universe how far do you push the kind of
supernatural stuff and how far do you
kind of introduce new characters are you
worried about what you're doing or you
just kind of like we're just gonna make
whatever works for this game and then be
whoever has to deal with the Blair Witch
universe next can figure it out no we
really want to I think that stick to the
original but we really want to stick to
the atmosphere of the original so we
careful with what we are adding we are
just adding the things that we believe
that will expand the universe in a most
natural way and we are obviously in
contact with lionsgate and they are very
supportive towards us like they are
saying oh but we knew in our own like
this is our backstage knowledge that all
right this works like this or this works
like this and we are always sticking to
what the originals suggested we although
we are creating new things we want to be
very grounded into what was shown in a
movie out of interest how do you kind of
get the history of and the law of Blair
which because you know you have
things like the Harry Potter guys they
can go to anything J can go to JK
Rowling there's like a you know a
bibliography or like a vast amount of a
library of Star Wars knowledge out there
is there like a Blair Witch kind of like
yeah they're reliable there is a lot of
side stories there's a lot of legends
you probably missed if you just watch
the movie right there is a lot of site
materials that are totally worth
checking out and yeah there is a lot to
work with okay awesome
well it sounds really intriguing I love
these supernatural games and I love like
you know pre this is your game so I'm
excited to see it all come together with
Blair which as well so when will people
be able to experience this and players
themselves it will be released on August
13th it's like two and a half months
from now excellent well better to play
it great thank you so much that's all
the time we have to talk about Blair
Witch but stay tuned we'll be back very
soon for more III 2019 coverage
[Music]
[Applause]